. Musik Musik Musik
Musik
Musik Er ist peinisch an mir festklammernd, wie immer. Stefan Tietze. Stefan Tietze, ich klammere peinisch an unserem Reiter fest, der The Rider des Podcast-Ufes, The Cowboy, der an dem alles hängt. Der Mann mit dem Cold, mit dem goldenen Cold. Dem Cold und einem Traum in den Augen und niemand weiss, wohin er reitet, aber jede Nacht verschwindet er. Aber ich denke, obwohl wir zu zweit sind, ich habe Angst vor dem Ziel, weil auch in der Stadt wird nur Platz für einen Cherish sein. Und auch auf diesem Pferd, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, habe ich auch das Gefühl, ist nur Platz für einen Reiter. Das habe ich am Anfang ein bisschen unterschätzt. Du hast es vor der Reise, vor Reiseantritt schon gesagt. Richtig. Dieses Pferd wird nur Platz für einen Cherish haben. Ich wollte, er habe gesagt, lass uns zwei Pferde mieten, du hast gesagt, nein, sei nicht albern, eins reicht. Du bist verschwenderisch, gehst du mit unserem Geld um, habe ich gesagt. Mit unserem Eingold-Säckel. Ja, mit unserem Eifel, wo auch nur eine schwere Münze drin ist. Wo wir ohnehin bei der Pferdevermietung den ganzen Säckel auf den Tresen gehauen haben, wo man sich fragt, vielleicht hätten wir für den gleichen Säckel auch zwei Pferde bekommen, weil so fein sind die Unterscheidungen in den Wilden. Es hat sowas wie beim Pokern All-In-Gehen, wo man dann denkt, wir geben jetzt eh alles ab, so was kriege ich dafür? Und ich habe das Gefühl, wir wurden ein bisschen verarscht. Aber das ist eine Woche her, du hast mich überzeugt, dass wir uns nur ein Pferd nehmen und jetzt sind wir hier. In einer Prärie, in einer wunderschönen Prärie auf dem Weg nach Little Rock. Ich dachte auch, du hast am Anfang nur grosse Reitangst und klammerst dich deswegen so panisch an mir fest, dass du mir die Luft abschnürst. Nein, seit einer Woche konstant hat sich auch nicht geändert. Das bleibt auch noch ein bisschen so. Ich freue mich auch nachts immer auf, wenn man absteigen kann dann endlich, abends ab 19 Uhr, wo man dann sagt, nee, jetzt schön, 7 p.m., wie man hier sagt, in der Nähe von Little Rock, wo wir bald ankommen.
Und nee, ich freue mich aufs Zelt dann auch immer, muss ich ja gar nicht ehrlich sagen.
Ich freue mich auch aufs Zelt, ich muss aber auf dem Rücken schlafen, weil deine Hände haben sich über den Tag so tief in meine Hüften eingegraben, die quasi schon meine Leber massiert.
Das ist aber auch gar nicht so unnötig, denn den ein oder anderen Whisky habe ich mir durchaus gegönnt. Und das Zeug haut ordentlich rein. Also das ist ja wirklich schon... Aber, aber alles wird besser, denn wir haben ja den Fahndungsbrief von dem Malcolm Brother. Richtig. Dem einen noch fehlenden Malcolm Brother. Den verbleibenden Malcolm Brother. Die anderen beiden haben uns andere schon weggeschnappt. Aber den verbleibenden Malcolm-Brother, der sich in Little Rock zurückgezogen hat. Leider der mit dem geringsten Lösegeld. Aber das ist uns egal, man kriegt zwei Goldsäckele. Ich freue mich darauf persönlich sehr. Wir sind auf dem Weg nach Little Rock. Und für zwei Goldsäckele kann man sich entweder zwei Klaviere oder zwei Bier kaufen. Also von daher unklar, wie viel das jetzt tatsächlich wert ist. Aber ich glaube, alleine die Tatsache, dass sein Lösegeld noch mal heruntergesetzt wurde, könnte schon genug sein, um ihn aus Little Rock rauszuholen. Ich glaube auch, er bringt uns um, einfach nur damit sein Lösegeld steigt. Was ich mir seit Wochen frage, während ich mich angst erfüllt an den Rücken klammere, ist, warum ist sein Lösegeld schon wieder gesunken? Da dachte ich, vielleicht dachte ich, vielleicht kam ich auf die Idee, dass er vielleicht was Gutes gemacht hat. Kann auch sein, dass er so eine Charity-Aktion oder so einen Fundraiser oder so gemacht hat und dann sozusagen sein Lösegeld kann er so peu a peu so ein bisschen. Und darum habe ich ein bisschen Angst. Deswegen bin ich auch froh, dass wir bald, bald, bald in Bill Rock schon ankommen. Wir müssen schauen nicht, dass er jetzt noch irgendwie anfängt, sich um Waisenkinder zu suchen. Ja, ein Waisenhaus öffnet. Weil was natürlich Schlimm, dass sein Lösegeld ins Negative geht. Ja. So dass, wenn wir ihn abgeben, noch was draufzahlen müssen, weil der Sheriff sagt, ja, was wollt ihr denn, das ist ein respektables Mitglied der Gemeinde. Ja, ja, jetzt ist das Lösegeld auf euch, sagt er dann plötzlich. So, das ist dann nämlich der Switch. Und das ist halt das Problem, wenn du kein Handy hast oder so, alles nur mit fucking Telegrafen, alle hundert Meilen hängen wir uns an den Telegrafenkabel ran. Und schreien, weil wir nicht genau wissen, was Telegrafen sind. Wir haben eine Dose und versuchen zu kommunizieren, aber es kommt nicht an, wir empfangen nichts und deswegen wissen wir gar nicht, wie der aktuelle Stand des Lösegelds ist. Ach, das bist du, ich dachte, das wären die Koyoten. Ne, ne, das bin ich, ich ruf jede Nacht. Ach, das wären die Koyoten, ich ruf jede Nacht. Ach, das wären die Koyoten, ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. Ich ruf jede Nacht. an den Telegraphenmast dran und schreie. Okay. Naja, aber es funktioniert nicht. Aber es ist so ein bisschen eigentlich wie im Buddhismus. Ist das die Idee, dass je besser du lebst, desto höher wird dein Wert und desto mehr steigst du auch auf? Also wenn ein Bandit jetzt richtig viel schlecht macht. Also Wilder Westen und Buddhismus, glaube ich, ist näher dran, als man denkt. Durch dieses Belohnungssystem, man kann aufsteigen, absteigen. Glaubst du, die Daltons sind heute noch unter uns als Pfauen vielleicht? Oder als vier verschiedene, wie heißen die, so Streifenmäuse, Streifenhörnchen? Streifenhörnchen. Die so vier dann so hoch gucken und unterschiedlich groß sind? Vielleicht, vielleicht. Was mich da mal anstellt, ist, dass der Grosse immer der Dohre ist. Das Gefühl, ich als grösser Mensch kämpfe immer so ein bisschen gegen das Vorurteil, der Grosse Dalton zu sein.
Ist immer der Grosse der Dumme.
Das heißt auch dick und doof.
Ja, ja, auch bei Dick und Doof ist der Grosse auch der Doofe.
Stimmt, aber die Dicken sind auch oft doof.
Also ich habe auch oft damit zu kämpfen gehabt, dass ich für doof gehalten wurde.
Aber eigentlich, wer ist denn nicht doof?
Aber diese doofen Ränder, an denen wir uns dann befindet haben, diese doofen... Ja, was Gewicht und Grösse angeht. Diese doofen körperlichen Extreme. Das heisst, wenn wir uns irgendwann zusammentun würden für ein Kult-Duo, jetzt mal als Beispiel, wären wir eigentlich doof und doof. Oder, ja. Würde auch nicht so gut funktionieren, glaube ich. Dick und gross, finde ich auch gut. Dick und gross. Ich bin zu doof, um nur ... Nee, ich bin ... Nee, dann wäre es ja ein bisschen leicht zu clever, um doof zu sein. Also dick und gross, finde ich eigentlich, wäre auf eine Art, da macht das schon Kompliment für mich. Irgendwann kommt der Punkt, wo wir uns auch einen dritten Kompagnon noch hinzusönen, dann sind wir gross und dick und doof. Und ich bete, dass ich gross bin.
Und dann ist der Durchbruch
steht kurz bevor, dann stürmen wir die Bühnen
mit gross und dick und doof.
Einfach vier Leute. Finde nicht schlecht.
Die Dortons kamen nicht so richtig rein, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe auch nie, war das,
was ich damals gesehen habe, Lucky Luke
als die Serie oder war das Dortons die Serie?
Ich weiß nicht, was du gesehen hast.
Die haben keine eigene Serie, nein. Aber es wurde natürlich ein bisschen deren Serie auch, weil die Dortons einfach so gut funktionieren als Konzept und man natürlich vier Actionfiguren verkaufen kann, weil du kannst ja nicht zu Hause zwei Dortons stehen haben. Also du kannst im Kinderzimmer was für ein lächerliches Kinderzimmer. Wohingegen Lucky Luke kaufst du einen, easy. Aber da brauchst du halt mehr. Bei Dortons würden drei reichen, theoretisch, um halt die Idee zu transportieren. Aber du weißt nie, wer der Grösste und der Kleinste ist bei drei. Du weißt nicht, habe ich den Grössten oder habe ich den Kleinsten. Du weißt es nicht genau. Also wie bei Power Ranger, wo du alle fünf brauchst, brauchst du bei den Dortons alle vier. Ist eigentlich genial. Ich habe eh das Gefühl, also hört man tatsächlich oft, wie solche Serien entstehen, ist einfach nur, um Spielzeug zu verkaufen. Auch so Pokémon, also genial, Pokémon hat unsere Jugend dominiert, wie sind sie darauf gekommen? Ja, ich dachte halt einfach, wenn die Kinder 150 Sachen kaufen müssen, kann man damit viel Geld verdienen. Ich finde es auch spannend, darüber nachzudenken, weil ich traue dir nicht, dass die laufen, ehrlich gesagt. Was ist denn los mit dir? Du verlierst dein Vertrauen in mich, du klammerst dich fest. Letztens hast du selber versucht, das Pferd zu reiten. Und warum vertraust du mir nicht mehr? Weil ich versucht habe, dich zu verkaufen an den Händler oder was? Das war das eine Red Flag. Andere Red Flag war, als du nachts im Schlaf versucht hast, mir den Fahndungssettel wegzunehmen für den Malcolm-Brother. Ich dachte, ich habe das verwechselt, im Mondlicht habe ich das nicht gut gesehen. Ich dachte, das wäre ein Booklet. Was mich nervt, strahlend hellen Mondlicht hier. Unfassbar hell. Das ist so hell. Unfassbar fucking hell. Das ist unser einziges... Ja, oder wir haben Fehler gemacht und wir schlafen tags. Ach nein! Nein! Scheiße! Na fuck! Oh nein, schon wieder, wir haben den Rhythmus umgedreht. Ich dachte, diese verdammte Zeitverschiebung, die wir langsam in einem sehr gesunden Takt einholen. Wie nervig, weil ich dachte auch, warum ist Nacht so fucking heiß und hell? Ich glaube, wir haben riesigen Fehler gemacht. Das stimmt schon, ja. Scheiße. Alles wirklich wahnsinnig hell, tut mir leid. Aber du kannst mir vertrauen. Ist doch Quatsch, wir sind seit Wochen unterwegs hier auf dem Pferd zusammen. Ja, ich dachte nur, vielleicht laufen wir nicht. Unser Graube-Podcast, ich weiß auch nicht, ob du das immer hochlädst. Wer hört das? Im Saloon teile ich Transkripte von unserem Podcast aus. Mach dir da mal keine Sorgen. Wann schreibst du die alle? Die erfreuen sich grosser... Hm? Wann schreibst du die alle auf? Auf dem Pferd. Ich habe doch meine Privatsphäre. Ich kann noch vorne auf dem Pferd machen, was ich will. Ja, das nervt mich sowieso ein bisschen, dass du dich immer so ein bisschen zurückziehst. Ja, wir haben ja gesagt, es gibt eine Linie und alles davor ist mein Bereich und alles dahinter ist dein Bereich. Ja. Nee, ist schon okay. Ich habe gesagt, ich brauche Privatsphäre, auch auf einem Pferd. Und du hast gesagt, anscheinend war es eine Lüge, als du gesagt hast, es ist okay für dich. Ich wollte dir gefallen. Jetzt kommt hier alles, wir sind noch nicht mal auf Little Rock, wir müssen danach wieder zurückreiten. Jetzt kommen hier die ganzen Sachen raus plötzlich. Ich habe schon gedacht, vielleicht bleibe ich in Little Rock. Was willst du denn in Little Rock? Du meinst, du bist zu klein, bist in die Stadt, ne? Ja, natürlich. Du bist ein riesiger Mann, Large Man in Little Rock, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, das ist eine gute Podcast-Folge, aber du weißt die Folge Large Man in Little Rock, das gefällt mir nicht ganz gut. Was ich sagen wollte, ursprünglich, bevor ich kontrolliert habe, ob wir auch wirklich laufen und das nicht alles ein riesengroß angelegter Prank von dir ist, ja, sorry, ich prank zu viel. Ich finde die Idee gar nicht so schlecht, nämlich ich bin jetzt auch wieder dabei, quasi so ein bisschen bisschen zu gucken, was könnten nächste coole Serienprojekte sein, Filmprojekte sein, was auch immer. Und ich finde es eigentlich total spannend, darüber nachzudenken. Geld zu verdienen. Gar nicht, aber so vom, weil man natürlich dann, wenn man anfängt, darüber nachzudenken, was könnte ein gutes Spielzeug sein oder ein gutes Filmposter zum Beispiel, dann fängt man natürlich an, so ein bisschen, sag ich mal, ik ikonografischer zu denken, also so ein bisschen mehr in, ich weiß nicht, in weirden, originellen Formen oder sowas. Ich will es nicht beschreiben, aber plötzlich werden Dinge so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, strahlender, grösser, weirder, also so dass man, weil, warum sollte man irgendwie eine Figur verkaufen
von einem normal angezogenen
Teenager zum Beispiel, hat ja keinen Sinn.
Verstehe, aber ein Seestern hingegen,
wenn deine Hauptfigur ein Seestern ist, oder der
Sidekick ist ein Seestern, kann man gut verkaufen,
erkennt man von weitem. Würde ich jetzt auch mal
sagen, vielleicht fehlt ihm noch eine Badehose,
eine geblümte gelbe Badehose.
Ist doch perfekt. Ja, aber das ist dann schon mal mehr
Wiedererkennungswert. Gibt's ja wahrscheinlich eine grosse Menge von Leuten, die Seesternen diese Badehosen anziehen, oder? Also hundertprozentig. Also vielleicht ein Riesenproblem, vielleicht ersticken die daran, dass Leute denen aus Spaß diese Badehosen anziehen. Könnte ein Riesenproblem sein. Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist das Problem von diesen Tieren, wo man nicht weiß, wo ist deren Augen, haben die Augen, wo sind deren Münder, haben die Münder, wie pflanzen sie sich fort, niemand weiß das. Ich meine, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, bei fünf Seesternarmen die Hose richtig anzuziehen? Beim ersten Versuch, jetzt haben wir die Stochastik raus, ist es eins zu fünf? Ich hätte es nicht rechnen müssen, ich wollte auch nicht mehr rechnen. Ich glaube, die Chancen im Seestern die Hose beim ersten Mal richtig anzuziehen, ist 1 zu 5, glaube ich. Ich glaube, es ist ungefähr 1 zu 5, ja. Ja, und dann schreien die dann um Hilfe, aber man hört sich über die Hose. Ja, weil die Trottel liegen auch auf ihrem Mund drauf. Wie dumm sind die denn, den Mund einfach nach unten zu haben? Ja, dumm oder mega bequem, cozy. So einfach so, ja, kann doch jeder Abend mal so ins Bett zu fallen, wie so ein Seestern auf dem Mund. Ja, das stimmt. Ist schon auch angenehm. Das stimmt, aber halt für die Podcast-Karriere eher schlecht. Also ich glaube, es gibt unter Seestern wenig wirklich richtig gut laufen. Ja, ist ein Problem. Aber ich finde das auch, also ich habe auch immer gehört, man soll keine Rochen mehr kitzeln. Das ist eine Information, die mit meiner Instagram-Timeline gespielt wurde. Und ich dachte, ja, ein guter Hinweis, falls ich mal in eine Situation komme, wo ich den Drang verspürt, Rochen zu kitzeln. Erstmal habe ich auch nie, es gab auch so Berührbecken oft mal im Sea-Life-Center, war ich damals an der Ostsee ein paar Mal drin, da gab es dann so Becken, wo man auch so Rochen berühren konnte. Das war für mich kein reizvolles Angebot, weil ich dachte, das sind Tiere, die möchte ich nicht so gern berühren. Obwohl ich finde es ein bisschen unfair, ich finde, wenn die Regel gilt, man soll ja keine Rochen kitzeln, dann will ich aber auch, dass die Regel gilt, dass Rochen mich nicht kitzeln dürfen. Weil das ist keine Einbahnstrasse, mein Freund. Kitzelkrieg ist keine Einbahnstrasse. Ja, weil das ist ja scheiß unfair, wenn jetzt so ein Rochen ankommt und anfängt, mich zu kitzeln. Ich darf mich nicht wehren. Was soll passieren? Eins, zwei, drei Kitzelkrieg? Soll ich dann auf Kissenschlacht umsteigen oder was? Das ist eine Gewaltspirale. Wir wissen nicht, wo die endet. Aber jetzt möchte ich mal dazu entgegnen, dass du vielleicht dem Rochen überlegen bist körperlich und deswegen ist es vielleicht doch eine Einbahnstraße zu regeln. Nein, Rochen sind super schwer zu kitzeln. Also diese flache Körperform ist ja fast evolutionär bedingt, dass die möglichst schlecht gekitzelt werden können. Der Mensch mit seinen schlabbrigen Gliedmassen überall, überall unter den Achseln, überall kannst du kitzeln. Kitzelig, ne? Ja, ein sehr kitzeliges Lebewesen, das stimmt schon.
So Aliens haben so in ihrem Lexikon stehen, Mensch und dann so, ich habe immer so ein Funfact, stelle ich mir vor, auf so Alien-Seiten, dann sind die bei uns Erdlinge und wir haben unten rechts stehen, sehr kitzelig. Besonders kitzelig. Vielleicht so, wenn wir irgendwann im intergalaktischen Rat ankommen und sagen so, wofür ist denn die Erde bekannt? Also was ist so unser Ding, was auf unserem Planeten, also wofür kennt man uns, was habt ihr so für Erwartungen an uns? Naja, zum einen seid ihr extrem ineffizient und verbraucht viel mehr, als dass ihr Energie gewinnt. Ja, okay, gut, aber ja, okay. Zum anderen seid ihr wahnsinnig nackt, ausser aus sehr spezifischen Stellen an eurem Körper. Ja, okay, stimmt. Sorry. Nehme ich mal als Feedback an. Jetzt hat es einfach sorry gesagt. Nehme ich mal als Feedback an, ja. Und dann seid ihr einfach wahnsinnig kitzelig. Kitzelig? Ja. Wir sind ausgesprochen kitzelig. Wir sind ausgesprochen exorbitant kitzelig. Das fällt uns gar nicht auf, nur im Vergleich. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mal bei Ihnen, Entschuldigung, wenn ich mal unter die Tentakel gehe. Ja, Moment, ich würde mir kurz mein Shirt, was man mir wieder falsch angezogen hat, hoch machen. Und wenn ich jetzt hier unter der Tentakel mal so ein bisschen Kille, Kille, Kille, Kille? Ne, ich verspülle einen leichten Kitzeldrang, aber wenn ich jetzt mal bei Ihnen rüberlangen dürfte. Ja, auf jetzt! Menschlich. Mit den acht Tentakeln ist das natürlich unfair, die Kitzel-Hierarchie ganz klar, wer hier oben steht und wer unten. Aber Spaß beiseite, Rochen leiden. Ja, auf, äh, kurz noch, äh, Rochen zu kitzeln. Rochen leiden und das Problem ist nämlich, dass man deren Nasenlöcher, und jetzt wird es halt weird, deren Nasenlöcher als Augen verinterpretiert, die sie unten haben, und deren Mund verziehen die halt, wenn man die kitzelt. Und dann reissen die ihre Nasen auf, was sieht aus, als ob die einfach, oder machen die ihre Nasen zusammen, weil wir auch stinken für die, und dann verziehen die ihren Mund so und es sieht aus, als ob die das lieben. Ach scheiße, das ist natürlich ungünstig, wenn dein Schmerzgesicht so aussieht wie, ah, mach weiter bitte. Das ist das Beste, was ich mir vorstellen kann, mach bitte weiter, weiter, weiter. Das heißt, kann man Rochen nicht einfach so böse Augen aufmalen, sodass man nicht mehr die Nasenlöcher als Augen verwechselt. Augenbrauen fehlen denen einfach. Einfach Augenbrauen. Fiese Augenbrauen. Oder halt eine Brille, dass man denen eine Brille aufsetzt, dass man klar sieht, wo die Augen sind, als Marker sozusagen. Wir setzen denen den Brille auf, aber dann haben wir in zehn Monaten das Problem, dass dann irgendwo bei Instagram steht, geben Sie Lochen nichts mehr zu lesen, kriege ich dann angezeigt. Bitte geben Sie Lochen nichts. Was man macht, ist es falsch. Also wirklich, was soll ich denn machen? Also das ist ja wirklich albern jetzt, aber das ist tatsächlich ein realistischer Hintergrund, weil wir haben ja lange, also erst haben wir lange gesagt, bitte füttert keine Schwäne. Dann haben wir gesagt, bitte füttert Schwäne, aber nur mit Nudeln. Dann haben wir wieder gesagt, bitte hört auf, Schwäne mit Nudeln zu füttern. Aber Gummibärchen sind glaube ich okay. So, und dann hin und her und hin und her. Und jetzt hatten wir uns eigentlich mal geeinigt auf, bitte füttert keine Tiere im Wasser, keine Enten, keine Schwäne. Jetzt habe ich aber ein Bild bekommen von einem Hörer, der mir ein Schild geschickt hat, Bild eines Schildes am Rand eines Sees. Bild eines Schildes am Rand eines Sees? Auf dem Stand, wir sind Enten, bitte füttert uns, dann sterben wir. Haben das die Enten aufgestellt? Ich glaube ja, ich glaube wirklich ja. Man sieht ja auch immer, wenn da an so einem Teich so ein Schild steht, bitte nicht füttern, dass da so Schnabelabdrücke auf dem Schild sind. Manchmal liegen da Federn daneben und das Schild ist ein bisschen krumm und man denkt sich, Moment mal. Hat das ein Mensch gebaut? Und dann gehen da so Fußabdrücke weg, so sehr, so recht, so leicht dreieckigeussabdrücke gehen dann so weg. Ich stelle mir nur vor,
in diesem Entennest, wie die so ein großes Bild von dem
Schild haben und alle entsammten kommen und wir
sagen, we gotta tear down the sign.
It's gonna go!
We have to tear it down!
Ja, aber es ist meine Frage,
haben wir es übertrieben, und das ist jetzt die schlimme
Entendysstopie, in der wir leben, dass die jetzt
nicht mehr alleine wissen, wie man Essen besorgt,
weil wir sie im Prolog
Vielen Dank. Es ist meine Frage, haben wir es übertrieben, und das ist jetzt die schlimme Entendysstopie, in der wir leben, dass die jetzt nicht mehr alleine wissen, wie man Essen besorgt, weil wir sie im Prolog so häufig gefüttert haben. Aber die Frage ist jetzt natürlich, wie machen wir weiter, erzielen wir sie zur Selbstständigkeit oder lassen wir sie verungern? Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht muss man sie wieder zur Selbstherrlichkeit erzielen, ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ein bisschen Selbstbewusstsein zusprechen. Ein bisschen, ah, du schaffst das schon. Hol dir den Wurm oder den Seetang oder was auch. Erstmal müssen wir lernen, was essen Enten. Larven, wahrscheinlich Larven. Kann auch sein. Oder Rochen. Und jetzt denkt man, wir dürfen die verfüttern, aber nicht kitzeln. Ich glaube, von einem Seestern können fünf Enten satt werden. Die können den sich richtig gut aufteilen, wie so eine Pizza, wo jeder genau ein Stück kriegt, die reissen den auseinander und es ist super snackbar. So ein Seestern ist einfach ein perfektes Snack. Jetzt kommt ein Hot Take, aber der Seestern ist für mich irgendwo in der Mitte zwischen Pflanzen und Tieren. Ja, absolut. Wir müssen nicht über die Seegurke sprechen, wo auch einfach schon die Benennung klar hinweist auf nicht ganz ein Tier, nicht ganz ein Tier, eher Gemüse, aber absolut. Ich denke auch gerade nach, es gibt ja eine Reihe von Eis, Schleckeissorten. Jetzt, ich denke an Dolomiti, ich denke an Flutschfinger, die also verschiedene Wassereisgeschmäcker kombinieren. Warum das nicht als Seestern? Du hast unten einen Stern als Griff,
einen Strahl, und die anderen vier kannst du dann wirklich so spitz
zuleckend verschiedene
Geschmäcker ablecken.
Ich war gerade bei so einem Hot Spring Breakers
Party-Ding,
wo fünf verschiedene Menschen von verschiedenen
Seiten anfangen, dich in die Mitte zu lecken.
Oh, finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Oder so ein Shot. Bitte? Du weißt nicht, was ein Shot ist. So ein Jello-Shot. Es gibt auch Jello-Shots. So Wackelpudding mit Alkohol. Ah ja. Und der in Form eines Seesterns. Und dann müssen sich fünf Leute finden, oder halt vier und Stefan, kommst du kurz, wir brauchen noch einen fünften. Ich setze in der Ecke und freue mich so sehr, weil ich noch nie gefragt wurde, bei diesem Spiel mitzumachen. Und dann hält Ashley in der Mitte den Jello-Shot-Seestern. Ja, aber Quinn. Vier heiße Münder und dein so ein bisschen mit so Labello dran, weil du Ausschlag hast von der Sonne. Und Zahnpasta noch. Man weiß nicht genau, ist es noch Sonnencreme, Labelle oder Zahnpasta?
So ein Spinatstück zwischen den Zähnen.
Und dann saugen alle gleichzeitig
an den fünf Enden des Seesterns und
saugen den so und dann trifft man sich
natürlich zu einem kurzen, schlüpfrigen
Kuss, zu einem Fünferkuss.
Genau. Und das ist sexy,
das ist cool, drunk,
hot, sexy und
das war, das ist mein Sommer, meine Sommeridee. Das ist unser Sommertipp, drunk, hot, sexy, Eis. Vielleicht ein bisschen spät, jetzt Ende September, aber guckt mal, was wir noch machen aus. Vielleicht lässt sich auch, vielleicht können wir, warum muss nur der Sommer sexy sein? Warum ist nicht fucking Christmas hot Christmas? Warum machen wir nicht dieses Weihnachten zum sexiest Christmas ever? Ich will Bikinis, ich will diese Weihnachtspullover, nein, Weihnachtsminirock, Weihnachtstanga, ich will Weihnachts, so Muscle Shirts, ich will All-In, Sexy Sandler. Show your guns, man. Ja, ich finde es nämlich auch. Ich will den Adventsstrip-Kalender.
Mit jedem Adventstürchen ziehst du ein Kleidungsstück aus
und an Weihnachten fucking all skinny dips.
Es geht los, schon morgens, wir sind bereit, wir haben Bock.
Finde ich auch gut, ist ja so ein bisschen die Idee von dem Eis.de Adventskalender
oder dem La Morelli, also verschiedene Sextoy-Hersteller,
die diese Adventskalender machen.
Aber die haben ja auch den Trend erkannt.
Ich glaube, es ist fucking heiß sein. Ich glaube auch, ich glaube, wir müssen ohnehin, jetzt wenn es immer heißer wird, glaube ich, wird eher der Sommer zum Nichtstun drin sein, der Jahreszeit, weil es zu heiß ist. Ja, man schwitzt ja auch im Sommer, da willst du ja nicht noch irgendwie andere körperliche Aktivitäten ausüben. Ja genau, ich glaube, es dreht sich genau um. Ich glaube, der Sommer wird prüde, langweilig drinbleiben und die Winterzeit ist die eigentliche Beachzeit. Ist ja auch mega, ist ja auch geil. Der Winter ist etwas Gemütliches, man kommt zusammen und so, das ist ja perfekt. Ja, let's make Christmas hot again. Let's make Christmas fucking sexy again. Ja, warum denn nicht, Leute? Warum denn nicht? Warum denn nicht? Finde ich mega. Finde ich richtig gut. Schön Après-Ski, Schlitten fahren und so geht eh nicht mehr. Wasserski fahren, einfach anstatt irgendwie Ischgl, sondern schön an die Riviera und da Wasserski zu Weihnachten. Du fährst gerade diese Slalom um Begriffe. Und man merkt, du hast keinen, ich weiß nicht, ob man als Skifahrer dann diese Törchen berühren muss. Du hast dich so versucht zu berühren jeweils, die Schlagwörter zu helfen. Alles, was ich weiss, ist, dass wenn du es nicht berührst, musst du ein kleines Stück ausziehen. Das zieht sich durch. Ich will einen Pole-Dance-Weihnachtsbaum haben, wo einfach schön jeder einfach tanzen kann, in der Mitte des Wohnzimmers, Oma ist dabei, alle haben gute Laune und ich sag mal so, die Päckchen, die ausgepackt werden, haben wir am Körper. Jeder packt sich zu Weihnachten in Weihnachtspapier ein und dann wird schön ausgepackt. Problem ist halt, dass Weihnachten sehr familiär ist. Ja, das stimmt ja. Also ich habe jetzt noch nie, ich habe jetzt noch nie, also das liegt ja auch an mir, an meinem Weihnachtsabend gehabt das Problem gehabt, dass es jetzt zu wenig hot war. Also vielleicht, ja. Ja, da müsste man natürlich gucken. Man müsste dann eher, die Vorweihnachtszeit ist ja lang. Man müsste, es ist voll, und vor allem, wir bräuchten dann halt auch so eine Art Christmas-Tinder, so dass man sich sozusagen nicht mit der eigenen Familie Weihnachten feiert, sondern mit heißen Teens und Twins aus der Nachbarschaft. Grinder. Um dann zusammen, wie der Grinch oder was? Ja, und Christmas. Christmas und Grinch. Ach so, Grinder. Grinder. Wie Grinch und Tinder. Verstehst du nicht?
Ja, der Grinch, ich finde eh Santa ist raus.
Wir nennen die App Grinder, wegen Grinch und Tinder.
Und damit könnt ihr dann eure hotten Partner kennenlernen für die hotte Weihnachtszeit, Grinder.
Ideale Idee. Ideal.
Richtig gut. Der Grinch wird zum neuen Helden.
Ja.
Der Grinch im Whirlpool.
Er hat ja auch ein bisschen was Anrüchiges, ne?
Ja klar, die Historie ist, komm mal her, komm mal ein bisschen näher.
Uff, ich bin ganz schwitzig schon, Stefan.
Ist es die Nachtsomme, die Nachthitze, oder was ist das hier?
Was macht dich am heißesten, meine Stimme oder mein kleiner grüner Körper?
Mein kleiner grüner, 60 Jahre alter Körper.
Stefan, ich wusste gar nicht, dass du so gut den Wünsche medieren kannst. Das ist ja ... Auch heiß? Kirche. Ja. Schön diese Holzbänke, wo man ein bisschen näher zusammenrücken muss, weil es ja doch sehr muckelig und voll in der Kirche wirkt. Ja, finde ich, kann man alles gut an. Man muss ja nochmal das Krippenspiel nochmal komplett umdichten mit den Engeln und dem heißen Esel und so, und dann einfach da nochmal komplett neu rangehen. Ja, und auch nicht Kinderspielen, da sind Kinder, wir machen auch einen Ü18 Gottesdienst, wo keine Kinder erlaubt sind, und ein Skrippenspiel sind dann so hotte, so Elite, Sex Education-artige SchauspielerInnen, die dann so anfangen, ein hotes Skrippenspiel aufzuführen, um mal zeigen, wie das Christuskind überhaupt entstanden ist. Finde ich gut, früher in der Antike oder so war das völlig normal, dass man irgendwelche Sexgötter hat und Dionysos Lustfeste gefeiert hat. Heute gar nicht mehr, alles prüde, alles langweilig. Warum nicht einfach sagen, das brauchen wir in unserer Gesellschaft, das auch noch. So, Bibel-TV, ihr hört ja zu, wissen wir ja. Wir hatten einen Shoutout übrigens in der Sendung. In der Late-Light-Show, ja, der christlichen Late-Night-Show. Grossartig, schaut es euch an, sie wird von Folge zu Folge besser. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, kann ich es nicht überurteilen, ich habe dafür zu wenig vorgelegt. Und die haben auch schon eine Sommer-Edition gemacht, schön am See, also die hatten schon ihren Hot Sexy Summer, Hot Christian Summer, also ich weiß nicht, ob die vielleicht zu Weihnachten dann da noch mal ein bisschen die Hitze hochd einen drauflegen, aber vielleicht, das wäre auch was, um die jungen Leute anzusprechen, um die Kirche zu bekommen mal wieder.
Wenn man sagt, so ein Ü18-Gottesdienst, wo alle halt nicht nur einen Schluck Wein bekommen, sondern so ein Short Wine, einfach so Jello Short Wine. Der Weinkeldich ist einfach pur Tequila oder sowas.
Und die Oplatte, die man isst, ist einfach so eine Zitrone, man muss reinbeissen.
Ja, genau. Das finde ich super. Der Leibkrist, die kriegst du so eine Zitrone, Schal, wenn die Hand gelegt, finde ich super. Und statt Weihwasser hast du so Salz, was man so in die Gemeinde streut. Genau, so Salz und so. Hast du alles dabei? Das ist perfekt. Mein Weihrauch ist vielleicht ein bisschen Weed. Uh, Leute, los geht's. Er hat ein bisschen zu viel Weinrauch gerochen.
Vor allem, es gibt auch keine Ministrantengruppe, die den Prank nicht schon mal gemacht hat, oder?
Ist doch in jeder Ministrantengruppe.
Irgendwann hau doch da mal irgendwie so ein bisschen, schön ein bisschen Ganja in den Weirauch rein, oder?
Wow.
Klar, natürlich.
Finde ich gut.
Das finde ich super.
Absolut Potential.
Und jeder hat so eine Flasche Wein einfach vor sich eh schon mal und kann die dann Köpfen während dieses anderthalb Stunden. Das macht auch mehr Spaß. Macht mehr Spaß. Hier, der Jello-Shot Christis ist für euch gestorben. Jetzt habt eine geile Zeit! Und dann einfach schön, wenn die Jello-Shots rauskauen. Man könnte vielleicht den Seestern auch da einsetzen. Oder das Kreuz. Du hast
ohnehin das Kreuz. Das sind Jell-O-Shots
als Kreuz. Vier Leute kommen
zusammen, vier Münder,
viel Alkohol, viele Umdrehungen.
Es wird heiß. Ja, es sind eher
alle schon breit an dem Zeitpunkt, weil
Weirauch ist, glaube ich, so auf der Setlist ganz
oben im Gottesdienst, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ich war sehr stark der Messdiener auch
immer. Ich habe auch nie den Ablauf verstanden und so.
Ich brauchte immer so einen Wink mit dem Zaun fahr.
Einen Wink mit dem Kreuz,
um vom Pfarrer um zu wissen, wo ich jetzt genau hingehen muss.
Ich habe mir nur gebetet,
samstags abends,
habe ich mir nur gebetet, dass ich morgens nicht der,
ich habe zu Gott gebetet, dass ich im
dass die Kirche ausfällt,
dass die Kirche nicht stattfindet.
Oder lass den Gottesdienst ausfällt. Lieber Gott, bitte, ich will mal nicht diesen Drecksgottesdienst besuchen. Und lass die Kirche abbrennen. Lieber Gott so, scheiße, was war ich denn jetzt? Jetzt habe ich aber verspricht. Ich meine, ich mag dich, ich mag dich, du bist einer der besten Ministranten, aber ich kann nicht, das wäre echt nicht, ja, vielleicht scheiße. Und ja, dann habe ich nur gebetet, dann zumindest, dass ich am nächsten Tag nicht der Messlinge mit den meisten Aufgaben, weil es gab ja auch so eine strenge Hierarchie zwischen den Leuten und manche mussten dann, das habe ich auch immer gehört, dann diese Kerzen halten, wo die dann häufig umgekippt sind. Die Ministranten oder die Kerzen? Die Ministranten sind häufig umgekippt.
Kerzen auch häufig umgekippt, lustigerweise.
Aber die Kerzen, da kommt ja oben einfach nur Kohlmonoxid raus oder so, weiß ich nicht.
Und die musst du direkt unter deine Nase halten.
Und du hältst die ja so zeremoniell vor dich hin.
Und da kippen rein, weil sie messen die da einfach um.
Das kann mir niemand erklären, dass diese Rituelle nicht irgendwelche Drogenursprünge hatten.
Dass die früher halt da irgendwie halt nicht eine normale Kerze hatten, sondern irgendeine weirde Weihrauchkerze oder so. Und dass das irgendwann puritanisch im 18. Jahrhundert irgendjemand einfach gesagt hat, habt ihr einen Schaden? Die ganze Ministerin ist ein Hai die ganze Zeit, mach das weg. Aber ich glaube, das ist die Idee. Das ist doch kein Zufall, dass du das direkt unter dich hältst, wie so eine Bong, dass du da unter dir schön da Feuerbrennen hast. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Ich kann es mir auch nicht vorstellen. Ich habe einfach primär Angst gehabt, dass ich derjenige wieder umkippt, hat den immer sehr weit weg von mir gehalten, sah auch strange aus. Ich wollte jedenfalls nicht derjenige sein, der, und dann gibt es ja am Ende noch diesen Chemiescheiss, wo dann ein Glas, so eine Wasserkanne und den Kelch und den Rotwein und so, und der wäscht dann erst den Kelch aus und dann macht er ein Brot und danach wäscht er es nochmal aus
und so, da kommt so eine Bastelstunde
zustande, wo dann auch alle irgendwie so
ihre Gargaben bringen müssen, die am Rand
platziert sind. Mürre.
Mürre.
Ein Messiner bringt Mürre. Scheiße, ich hab die Mürre vergessen.
Ja, dann wird der gesagt, bring mal die Mürre
jetzt nach vorn und du gehst zu so einem Tisch, wo so
sehr viele Gewürze ausgebreitet
sind und dann bring mal Mürre. Ja, ja klar, ich wüsste jetzt auf Anime auch nicht, also grob, ich glaube, jeder weiß grob, wie Mürre aussieht, aber genau in Unterscheidung jetzt zu anderen Gewürzen oder Sachen. Man hofft, dass er sagt, bring jetzt mal Paprika, das erkenne ich. Ja, bring mal das Knoblauchsalz, so, das kannst du, da kannst du orientieren. Bring mal so Basilikum, easy, bring mal Mürre. Ist schwierig, ist schwierig, du, du hast ja einen guten Job gemacht, ist ein harter Job. Und ich glaube vor allem dann, wenn nach Sexy Christmas alle richtig zufrieden, breit betrunken sind, dann mal so einen geilen Christstollen einfach. Ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein anderes Erlebnis, so ein riesiger Christstollen, wo alle ausgepowert irgendwie, alle haben richtig
alles gegeben, nackt, schwitzig
liegt man ineinander verschlungen da.
Und dann einfach dieser
geile Christstollen,
dieser Puderzucker, einfach alles ist
voller Puderzucker, man weiß nicht,
welche verschiedenen Pulver hier in der Luft liegen,
alles ist da und
es ist grossartig. Ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein anderes
Erlebnis. Und dann auch Silvester machen wir mal nichts. Ja genau, Silvester werden wir zu Hause. Silvester machen wir dann mal einen ruhigen Tag. Das geht nämlich auf die Nerven, dass jetzt schon so gefühlt die Planung losgehen, wo man Silvester feiert und was auch immer. Nein, das wollen wir nicht immer so viel Aufmerksamkeit und Rampenlicht auf dieses Datum legen. Das ist doch nervig, nächstes Jahr. Nein, wir machen Heiliger Abend, erster, zweiter Weihnachtsfeiertag, machen wir durch, drei Tage durch, drei Tage wach. Einfach, fuck it, wir haben genug Puderzucker da, um durch die Nacht zu kommen, kein Problem. Genug Grinderdates, Grinch-Tinder-Dates und dann schön Silvester ins Bett gehen. Einfach schön in die Badewanne und locker. Spätestens um halb zehn bin ich im Bett, Silvester. Ja, oh ja. Das sage ich euch. Oh ja. Finde ich gut. Ah, toll. So, jetzt wird es wieder hell, dann müssen wir uns jetzt wieder hinlegen, unser Zeltchen. Ach nee. Wollen wir eine Nacht mal durchmachen? Aber jetzt ist unser Rhythmus ja komplett im Arsch. Ja, mal gucken, wird es nicht noch heller vielleicht? Ja, das kann man nicht genau sagen. Okay, dann reiten wir noch ein bisschen weiter. Wie kann man die Sonne und den Mond unterscheiden, wenn man nicht weiß, ob es gerade Tag und Nacht ist? Hitze, glaube ich. Hitze? Aber jetzt habe ich ja falsch gelegen einfach. Ja, und du machst immer so ein riesiges Feuer. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum. Ich sage mal, lass uns so ein lockeres Lagerfeuer machen. Und bei dir sonnenwendartig riesiges Flammeninferno. Ja. Wir denken, man sieht uns auf Kilometer. Wir sehen alles auch auf Kilometer. Ich weiß nicht, wessen Sonne strahlt heller? Die neben uns, die über uns? Oder der Mond. Der Mond. Ich habe völlig die Orientierung verloren. Nee, ich mache immer ein sehr großes Feuer, das stimmt, weil ich denke, das hält uns vielleicht warm. Ja, und dann kommen die ganzen fucking Motten an und die Insekten aus ganz, die Riesenmotten, aus ganz South Carolina
aus Most Town
South Carolina kommen dann die
Riesenmotten angeflogen.
Das war ein Problem,
das war das Problem, als sie mich einmal weggetragen haben,
die grossen Motten, dass die Riesenmotten
ankamen und mich geschnappt haben, vom Pferd
gerissen haben, das war ein Problem.
Das darf nicht immer vorkommen, manchmal aber auch kleinere
Feuer. Die sind immer noch so gross, gebe ich dir recht, aber so osterfeuerartig. Ich finde das immer irgendwie nett. Zur Ablehnung Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr da alle reinfliegen. Ja. Die fucking Enttäuschung von Motten, oder? Wenn die denken, Alter, Licht, geil, und dann einfach den ganzen Abend dip, dip, dip, dip, dip gegen den Lampenschirm, einfach den ganzen Tag. Oder haben die da, also haben die da richtig Bock auf Licht oder ist es enttäuschend für die? Aber was ist das denn überhaupt für eine Idee, auf Licht zu fliegen? Was ist denn gesund? Also was ist in der Natur, wo gibt es in der Natur gesundes Licht? Mond, ich glaube, das ist wirklich so ein Orientierungsding, dass die immer Richtung Mond oder Sterne fliegen. Ich glaube, die wollen eigentlich Astronauten sein. Die wollen weg von der Erde. Ich wollen sie im Heimatplaneten. Oh ja, das kann gut sein. Ja. Ja, und leider haben die nicht damit, haben die, die Aliens dachten, die Menschen sind zu kitzelig, um jeweils Licht zu erfinden oder Feuer zu erfinden. Weil die Distanzen sind ja enorm, du schickst es ja los eine Million Jahre, bevor das da ankommt, wo die Menschen angeguckt haben und gesagt haben, ach Quatsch, die sind zu kitzelig, aus denen wird nichts.
Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, kommt zurück, fliegt ins Licht. Und jetzt haben wir Menschen über Licht gemacht, Gelanden, Lichterketten, Laternen und hunderte Motten und Insekten schwärmen da rum und wollen nach Hause eigentlich. Ich verstehe halt auch nicht genau. In der freien Wildbahn ist doch das einzige,
was hell ist, der Mond,
der zu weit weg ist, die Sonne, die zu weit weg ist,
Sterne, die zu weit weg sind oder halt so was wie
Feuer, wo wenn du reinfliegst,
tot bist. Ja, oder ein Komet oder
sowas. Oder halt
einer von den zahlreichen Kometen.
Das heißt, als Motte
bist du ja eh in
sagen wir mal 80 Prozent der Lichtquellen, die du fliegst, tot, auch ohne jetzt den kitzelnden Menschen. Ja, eigentlich ist die Halogenlampe ein Segen für die Motten, hat deren Todesrate massiv runtergesetzt, weil sie nicht alle sofort sterben, wenn sie es folgen. Aber was ist denn jetzt, das ist doch scheiße, wenn du jetzt so Icarus bist und du lernst ja deine Lektion nicht. Wenn du zu nah an die Sonne fliegst, Icarus ist zu nah an die Sonne geflogen, hat seine Lektion gelernt, ist jetzt am Teppich geblieben. Aber Icarus, der zu nah an der Halogenlampe geflogen ist, lernst seine Lektion nicht. Halten wir die Motten zurück? Ja, das meine ich nämlich. Wir halten nämlich, weil ich glaube nämlich die dummen Motten fliegen ins Licht. So, und die, das ist so eine natürliche Auslese, die werden getötet. So, aber bei uns überleben auch die dusseligen Motten, wir halten die zurück, die Lernere Lektionen werden die niemals lernen, die cleveren Motten, weil die nie ihren Freund Jerry ins Feuer fliegen sehen, sondern gegen die Halogenlampen und dann kommt Jerry wieder und sagt, ich war da, es war nicht geil. Ich glaube, Motten haben auch die langweiligste Mythologie und die langweiligsten Heldengeschichten aller Zeiten. Es gab mal eine Motte, die flog hoch zum Licht.
Und die Legende sagt, sie dotzt heute immer noch dagegen.
Und...
Was ist dann passiert? Was ist dann passiert?
Will jemand einen Pullover? Will jemand einen leckeren Pullover haben?
Naja, ich hatte schon sehr viele Pullover von Stefan.
Der, dem fress sich alle seine Sachen weg. Njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, n. Hat mir jemand ausprobiert, das einfach machen zu lassen? Einfach so einen Anzug in den Raum? Ne, jemand hängt so Klebedinger, diese fiesen, türkisvollen Klebestoffartige Dinger dahin. Oder Lavendel, was sie auch nicht mögen. Also verstehe auch nicht, sie lieben Licht, hassen Lavendel. Ja, das ist einfach ein Duft aus den 90ern, das ist denen einfach zu alt, das ist denen einfach zu kitschig. Nee, aber hat man versucht, die einfach machen zu, gewähren zu lassen? Ja, den einfach mal so einen schönen Stoff, einfach so einen Leidenstoff oder so einen Anzug und dann die Motten einfach mal machen zu lassen. Vielleicht ist das die neue Generation der Modebranche, einfachfach Moth-Fashion. Mothen.
Weil das einfach der nächste
Held ist Mothen.
Wo wir ein Label gründen?
Mothen?
Mothen.
Alle Designs stammen exklusiv aus Mottenhand?
Ja, Mothen. Und dann so 2021 Berlin.
Ja, das finde ich richtig gut.
Finde ich richtig gut.
Mothen.
Finde ich eine richtig gute Idee.
Wir lassen sie machen.
Aber was ist die Grundlage? Oder legen wir denen wirklich einfach so diese Leinentücher aus, roh und die schneiden dann da was. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein Riesenraum, ein gleißend heller Raum, damit die sich zu Hause fühlen. Ja, das ist jetzt mal wohlfühlen. Damit sie sich wohlfühlen und erst mal nichts anderes wollen. Oder wenn der Nachbar mal Licht anmacht. Nee, die dürfen nicht raus. Dass sie dann nicht das Gefühl haben, ich will jetzt nach Hause. Nein, die wollen sich wohl bei uns fühlen, also im gleichen Tellerraum und du hast in der Mitte, einfach hängt oben so ein Tellerbügel in der Mitte des Raumes, dass sie von allen Seiten quasi sich selbst verwirklichen können. Ja, finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Und dann so eine Fashion-Show, die aber auch, sind die Models dann schon Menschen, müssen schon Menschen sein.
Ja, natürlich.
Schon für Menschen.
Wobei wir wissen natürlich nicht, was die Motten aus den Sachen machen.
Vielleicht tragen die auch kleine Schnipsel weg und bauen dann quasi so an so kleinen Püppchen irgendwie so ihre eigene Mottenkleidung.
Ziehen die selber was an.
Vielleicht müssen wir denen schon so Puppen geben, so mit Menschen Puppen, dass die daran dann was machen.
Einfach mal gucken, was passiert.
Ich glaube, das hat wirklich noch niemand gemacht, zu schauen, was passiert und das einfach dann richtig teuer zu verkaufen. Wir sind auch einfach zu ungeduldig, die Menschen. Aber es werden alles Unikate, man könnte das richtig teuer verkaufen. Und um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich finde, die Modewelt braucht mal ein bisschen frischen neuen Wind. Ach, das muss ich wissen. Was sind denn deine Impulse? Ich habe in die Herbstkollektions mal reingeguckt und ich muss sagen, ziemlich uninspiriert, unbeeindruckt, Brauntöne, Erdtöne, irgendwie, das ist für mich so 2017, das kann ich nicht mehr sehen, wo ist die Innovation? Du hast entweder Retro oder was Neues, Retro oder was Neues, langweilig, ich will mal was ganz anderes. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, du willst was Neues. Ja, aber nicht so etwas, wo man sagt, oh, das ist jetzt neu, das gab's noch nie. Ich will was, was es schon mal gab, aber was ich sage, wow, das habe ich so noch nie gesehen. Das werde ich auch häufiger mal sagen. So immer, ich kann ja auch alles anwenden, Filme, alle Filme, entweder Retro oder was ganz Neues, entweder Retro oder was ganz Neues. Und alle so, ja, was willst du denn? Ja, was anderes. Ich will genau, ich will die dritte Dimension. Ich will die dritte Dimension. Du willst ins Licht fliegen. Ich will ins Licht fliegen. Ich will die Moth-Fashion. Oder Forth. So ein richtiges Arschloch, wenn er zurückgekommen wäre und nicht gestorben. Ja. Ich war da, Leute. Ich war da. Das ist eine Riesenscheibe, wo man gegenfliegt und dann hat sie so leicht geflackert und dann bin ich wieder zurückgekommen. Arschloch. Ja, richtig unangenehm. Zum Glück ist er abgestürzt, fucking. Ist er dann auch gestorben, oder? Fast, glaube ich. Er hätte nur ins Wasser gefallen und er hat gesagt, huch! Und das war's. Ich glaube, die Steaks waren nicht so hoch damals, oder? Er hat auch niemandem davon erzählt, weil er wollte nicht, dass diese Scham-Geschichte weitergeführt werden. Ja, kann sein, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Das dauert auch nicht mehr lange, bis das verfilmt, oder? Ich meine, es wird ja alles verfilmt. Einfach Icarus. Und alle so, wie geht das aus? Wie wird das ausgehen? Der will mit seinen, das war auch ein bisschen arg unrealistisch, oder? Weil er ist zu hoch geflogen und es wurde zu warm. Meiner Erfahrung nach, je höher man geht, desto kälter wird es. Ja, er ist weiter geflogen als du. Der ist über... Aber im All ist es doch auch super kalt. Machst du das gerade eine griechische Sage oder eine römische Sage? Sorry, um euch hier mal eure Emissionen zu zerstören, aber Icarus debunkt. Je höher du gehst, desto kälter wird es. Völlig richtig. Ich meine, irgendwann bist du so nah an der Sonne vielleicht, aber da musst du schon ... Ja, weil da ist ja auch nicht warm, du hast ja völlig recht, im Weltall ist es ja kalt. Ja. Und unser Bild ist ja nur warm, weil wir unsere Treibhausgase haben, weil wir unsere CO2 haben, weil wir unsere Pups und Küche haben. Weil wir unsere guten alten Freundes CO2 haben. Ja. Ja. Ich, ja. Nein, also Bullshit. Bullshit, Wachsflügel, kompletter Nonsens. Die bankt. Icarus die bankt. Weg damit, weg damit. Satan ab, äh, Tünn, äh, sorry, Santa abgeschafft, Entschuldigung, Weihnachtsmann abgeschafft, durch einen Grinch ersetzt, Icarus abgeschafft, wird ersetzt durch Prometheus, oder? Mal so ein Prometheus-Charakter. Ich glaube, das Feuer. Satan ist eigentlich in der Geschichte ein ganz interessanter Charakter. Ja, super. Ich bin mal vor einiger Zeit mit dem Auto mit Schweizern durch die Schweiz gefahren. Und das zieht sich auch durch dein Leben, Leben, oder? Ja, und das war richtig interessant. Und die sind da schon tausendmal durch diese Berge, es war mit Gotthard da irgendwo, sind die schon ein paar Mal so drum gefahren. Und die haben mir dann eine Geschichte erzählt von der Teufelsbrücke. Denn es gibt, das ist jetzt so eine Riesenschlucht wirklich, man fährt ja unglaublich hoch und das ist eine riesensteinige Schlucht. Und im Mittelalter wollten die gerne eine Brücke über diese Schlucht bauen. Und zwar nennt man das die Teufelsbrücke, weil der Teufel gesagt hat, ha ha, ihr wollt diese Brücke bauen, ich baue euch diese Brücke. Er war kein Schweizer, der Teufel war kein Schweizer. Ich baue euch diese Brücke, er war kein Schweizer, hat gesagt, aber nur, wenn mir die erste Seele gehört, des Ersten, der über diese Brücke geht. Ja, easy, kein Problem. Das Dorf hat gesagt, ja, okay. Und der Teufel... Hätten wir da nicht besser verhandeln können? Ihr habt sofort Ja gesagt. Okay, ihr habt Ja gesagt, ihr habt Ja gesagt. Und der Teufel hat diese Brücke gebaut. Und die sind wirklich einfach aus wie eine Teufelsbrücke. Die sind einfach so sehr pragmatisch, so Herr-der-Ringe-artig aus, da wo dann da bei Moria so Kasadum-artige Brücke. Und in dem Moment, wo die mir das erzählt haben, bin ich weitergefahren und es kam auch diese Brücke plötzlich, war zu sehen. Das war interessant und toll. So, und dann lag da ein riesengroßer Felsbrocken. Und ich habe mich gefragt, was ist ein Felsbrocken? Da haben die mir dann erklärt, nee. Okay, dann war es nämlich so, die haben nämlich das Dorf, hat dann nämlich den Teufel verarscht. Da haben die nämlich einen Huhn über die Brücke gehen lassen. Und der Teufel hat gesagt, gib mir die Seele von dem Ersten, der über die Brücke läuft. Und die haben das Dorf, hat das Loophole gefunden und hat einen Huhn drüber gehen lassen. Und der Teufel war sauer. Jetzt hat er nur diese Huhnseele bekommen und hat einen riesengroßen runden Felsen genommen, auf das Dorf geworfen. Der lag da auch, aber er hat das Dorf verfehlt. Weil eine alte Frau aus dem Dorf hat ein kleines Kreuz auf diesen grossen Felsen gemalt. Und es war dann ein Gottesfelsen. Moment mal, bevor er ihn geworfen hat? Die alte Frau wusste schon im Vorhinein, welchen Stein der Satan werfen würde. Ja, jetzt debunkte ich auch noch diese Geschichte. Ich weiß, du bist gerade im Debunk-Modus. Aber ich fand's mega, weil wir sind dann auch an diesem Felsen vorbeigefahren, der war riesig und rund und der war so unwirklich und da war bestimmt noch ein kleines Kreuz irgendwo reingeritzt. Und das fand ich erst fantastisch. Und er hat das Dorf verfehlt, das Dorf hatte die Brücke, alles gut und die Brücke gibt's heute noch. Ich finde, der Satan ist nicht der beste Bösewicht, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Er wirkt nicht so wahnsinnig kompetent, zumal man ja glaube ich rein christlich-theologisch schon anmerken muss, dass Hühner haben auch Seelen. Ja, also Hühner sind auch im Himmel. Gibt es einen separaten Hühnerhimmel oder sind im Menschenhimmel auch die Hühnerseelen? Es sind auch nervig viele Hühner da. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Vor allem seitdem wir die männlichen Küken umbringen, ist der Himmel einfach voller Küken wiederum. Das ist schon ganz geil. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Je mehr Küken wir töten auf der Erde, desto mehr haben wir im Himmel Küken. Aber altern die da nicht und werden irgendwann so Tiger King-artig, haben dann so ein Problem, dass die zu alt werden. Alterst doch im Himmel nicht mehr. Stell dir vor, du kommst in den Himmel und dann alterst du noch weiter. Unendlich lange Zeit. Das geht ja nicht. Du musst ja schon so bleiben, wie du bist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so Sinn ergibt. Aber auch da Satan, glaube ich, kommt ja in der Bibel nie wirklich vor. Das einzige, glaube ich, ist so die Schlange im Paradies, wo man sagt, die war schon fies. Aber ist ja auch geil, weil wenn man sich das mal durchliest, wie das mit der Schlange ablief, die alle drei, die Prankster, die drei Prankster, Adam, Eva und Schlange, wurden ja bestraft. Das heißt, Gott hat gesagt, ihr habt jetzt hier den Apfel gegessen, obwohl ich euch eigentlich explizit gebeten habe, ihn nicht zu essen. Gut, aber ihr habt es trotzdem gemacht. Und jetzt werde ich euch bestrafen. Und die Strafen sind ja das Allergeilste, die Gott sich überlegt für die drei. Erstmal, der Mann kriegt die Strafe, dass er im Schweiß seines Angesichts auf dem Feld arbeiten muss. Also anders als im Paradies, wo man alles umsonst hat, muss er arbeiten. Die Frau erleidet Schmerzen bei der Geburt, wo man schon mal sich überdenken kann, okay, die Leute, die die Bibel geschrieben haben, müssten sich damals schon gedacht haben, was ist das für ein Scheiß, dass es Schmerzen bringt, jemanden zur Welt zu bringen? Das muss doch irgendwie so eine Strafe Gottes sein, oder? Ja, schon. Und die Strafe für die Schlange ist ja die allergeilste. Die Schlange kriegt die Strafe, dass sie ab jetzt über den Boden kriechen muss. Wo man erstens fragt, im Gegensatz zu davor, wo sie wie so ein ICE einfach so über den Boden geschossen ist. Sie schoss so Magnetschwebelwahnartig, hat sie das Erdmagnetfeld genutzt, um einfach so drüber zu fliegen. Auch das, finde ich, sagt einiges über die Autoren der Bibel aus, weil die sich irgendwann eine Schlange angeschaut haben und gesagt haben, kommt der dir einen Trottel an, verdammt den Depp an. Verdammt, bis in alle Ewigkeit. Muss hier herumkriegen. Vollidiot, wie ein Tier. Wahrscheinlich war das irgendeine Strafe Gottes, dass der Depp da so am Boden rumkriechen muss, anstatt zu laufen. Also auch hier sieht man das Wertesystem der Leute damals. Und sieht nur der Vogel da oben, der rumfliegen muss. Die Strafe Gottes.
Fliegen? Ja,
ist doch genauso weird.
Alles, was nicht auf zwei Beinen ist,
finde ich weird und ist eine Strafe
Gottes. Habe ich recht? Okay, Matthäus,
dann schreib du deine eigene Bibel und dann
schauen wir mal, welche sich durchsetzt
auf dem Markt, okay?
Ein bisschen weird in Fassung.
Aber das finde ich schon geil, einfach zu sagen, die Strafe ist Schmerzen in der Geburt, was die Leute dachten, Ich bin ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist einassung. Aber das finde ich schon geil, einfach zu sagen,
die Strafe ist Schmerzen
in der Geburt, was die Leute dachten,
das klingt wie so ein Stand-up-Bit.
Leute, warum tut es eigentlich weh,
Kinder zu kriegen?
Strafe Gottes und die Schlange,
die kriechen muss, finde ich grossartig.
Finde ich auch grossartig. Was hat die Schlange gemacht?
Ich finde dein Tweet sehr lustig,
warum Schlangen nicht mal einfach runterrollen von Bergen, wenn die dann schneller sind? Das checken sie aber, glaube ich, nicht. War das dein Tweet, da habe ich das geträumt. Ne, das habe ich getwittert. Du bist ja im Twitter-Game drin, freu uns. Ich bin im Twitter-Game, ich bin zurück und es gefällt mir, ich habe viele Zuspruch bekommen von Biologen, die sich ähnliches mal gestellt haben, es gibt anscheinend Spinnen, die Hänge runterrollen können. Ah. Lass uns mal ganz kurz hier eine Pause machen. Nee, es geht weiter. Okay, alles cool. Ich hatte ganz kurz Angst, dass unser kleines, schäbiges Holzaufnahmegerät, das du viel zu teuer in einem Saloon gekauft hast, kaputt gegangen ist. Aber es geht noch. Ja, und ganz ehrlich, wenn wir zwei Pferde gekauft hätten,
wäre kein Platz mehr gewesen für das Holzaufnahmegerät.
Bisschen wir wie gesagt nicht, weil wir
alles, was wir bezahlt haben, mit einer Münze bezahlt haben.
Von deiner riesigen goldenen Münze.
Ist dir auch mal aufgefallen, dass auf diesen Münzen nichts
draufsteht? Also nicht irgendwie
fünf Mark, zehn Mark
oder gulden oder denar.
Einfach nur
Stücke. Aber ist nicht auch schön, dass man einfach das bekommt, was dem anderen diese Münze wert ist? Ist doch schön, dass jeder einfach andere... Vielleicht kann ich auch mit diesem Stein bezahlen. Vielleicht hat der einen Wert für irgendwen. Ist doch schön, dass nicht alles immer so ein Label hat. So einen Preis. Ich würde den Stein abkaufen. Für wie viel? Was ist dir der Stein wert? Ja, ist ja nur ein Stein. Aber ist ein schöner Stein, ist ein flacher Stein. Kannst du mit wegwerfen in so ein WC und dann kann der ein paar Mal aufdötzen. Ja, ja. Ist doch schön gerade. Einen Säckel Münzen? Meinen Säckel Münzen für den Stein? Ich habe leider nur eine Form von Währung. Entweder ich gebe dir gar nichts, oder ich gebe dir meinen gesamten Säckel. Dann nehme ich lieber nichts, behalte lieber. Nein, warum denn? Ich gebe dir das Säckel und das Pferd. Ja, Deal. Okay, alles klar, Deal.
Idiot.
Ah, mein guter, guter Stein.
Ich bin nach so einem Deal gut, wenn beide gleichzeitig sagen Idiot.
Vielleicht gleichzeitig dreist.
Aber heisst es, dass du jetzt reitest?
Ja.
Nein.
Oder weg, weg, weg, weg.
Okay, gerade, Moment, du willst aber nicht stehenbleiben.
Du willst nicht stehenbleiben.
Was sind die Comments? W für geradeaus, A für links. Br aber nicht stehenbleiben. Du willst nicht stehenbleiben. Was sind die Comments?
W für geradeaus, A für links.
Brr für stehenbleiben, ne?
Ja, aber Brr, das funktioniert selten.
Ich glaube, wir haben Schwierigkeiten mit der Brr-Flüssigkeit.
Das funktioniert momentan nicht.
Also Brr nicht?
Nee.
Was ist Gas?
Nee, lieber Hilfe, Hilfe, ich will stehenbleiben.
Was ist Throttle?
Gas?
Einfach nach vorne lehnen.
Leicht nach vorne lehnen. Leicht nach vorne lehnen.
Leicht nach vorne lehnen und schön die Hand nach vorne ausstrecken für den Ballopp.
Das finde ich auch gut.
Dieses Einlass, ein von diesen Halftern, nee, Zügel.
Zügel.
Was ist Halfter?
Halfter ist da, wo die Pistole drin ist.
Okay, ja.
Aber ich bin schon grob im Cowboy-Dingo.
Kann es sein, dass sie der schlechteste Cowboy sind, den ich je gesehen habe? Aber Sie haben mich gesehen. So it may seem. Und falsches Franchise. Ja, dann muss ich dem Fall erst die Spuren geben oder macht man das nicht mehr? Nee, das hat schon Spuren, passt schon. Er ist alles bereit, wir sind nicht mal angehalten, wir reiten sogar noch weiter. Wir reiten einfach weiter. Wir haben einfach den Wechsel athletisch hinbekommen. Das merkt das Pferd gar nicht. Aber cool, dieses einfach schon unnötig. Das Pferd hat jedes Mal so, ich komme auch so mit. Ist es, wenn man Filme guckt und die machen das, ist es Clicking Teeth oder Clicking Tongue oder Sucking Tongue oder Sucking Teeth? Ne, Sucking Teeth ist das. Ja, Sucking Teeth habe ich auch mal nachgeschlagen, weil das mal in einem Lied vorgekommen ist als Lyric. Suck your teeth, habe ich nicht verstanden. Ja, es ist ja, es ist ja genau. Ja, coole, coole halt einfach. Ich glaube eh, dass sich viel Coolness im Mund abspielt. Coolness? Ich dachte, es wäre so ein, na shit, das ... Nee, nee. Sack your teeth? Ich weiß es leider auch nicht genau. Ich glaube, das ist ein anderer Kulturraum. Aber das macht man schon, wenn man cool sein will. Aber ich denke zum Beispiel an den Strohalm. Den Strohalm im Mundwinkel. Du meinst einen richtigen, echten Weizen-Strohalheim. Als Cowboy natürlich haben wir beide leider. Wir haben beide gleichzeitig dieses Alleinstellungsmerkmal uns überlegt. Und dann sind wir in die Stadt gekommen und haben gemerkt, dass jeder einzelne Stadtbewohner diesen Stroheim im Mundwinkel hat. Und das und Kautabak hat auch jeder. Und wir uns dachten, verdammt nochmal, was können wir uns abheben von dieser Masse an Cowboys, die alle exakt gleich aussehen. Ich habe neulich über diesen Podcast gehört, so einen indigestikativen journalistischen Podcast, wo dann jemand interviewt wurde. Und dann gab es einen Disclaimer vor diesem Interview. Das Geräusch, was ihr hört, ist wahrscheinlich das Geräusch von Coutabac, das er dann ausspuckt. Und dann wurde in das Gespräch geschnitten und es war so ein alter Drogenboss, der, glaube ich war das, der dann angefangen hat, einfach so zwischendurch hat man immer so ein metallendes Klacken gehört. Und dann hat er wahrscheinlich irgendwo so eine Metallschüssel stehen gehabt. Dieser Spucknapf. So ein Spucknapf war dann reingerotzt, ein Kautabak. Und dann hat er immer gesprochen, so, I guess in the end it was like, bling. Oh, cool. Ja, und es war weird, es war richtig seltsam. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, Coolness kommt aus dem Mund. Kautabak, Strohhalm, Suck Your Teeth, irgendwie all diese Sachen, auch Zigarette oder sowas, hat alles, glaube ich, Mundkontakt. Ich finde, da sind wir in der richtigen Sache auf der Sprache. Auch so ein Lutscher kann auch cool sein. Was treibt dich in diese gottverlassene Gegend? Ja. Ich glaube auch, dass du im Western, weil die Westernhelden sind ja in der Regel sehr wortkarg. Ja, wir nicht. Das stimmt. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir machen da auch viel falsch. Wir haben viele Close-Ups. Super viele Close-Ups. Alle immer der Schweigsame, wir sind die schnatternden, die beiden schnatternden. Halt ihn mal den Mund! Ja, also auf jeden Fall habe ich dann, bekomme ich den Salon rein und dann und dann sagt er mir das auch zu mir. Ich denke jetzt, Andy Moikon ist auch richtig sauer, weil wir anderen labern die ganze Zeit durch. Der ganze Film ist nur wir beiden sind am Schnattern und schnattern. Und er kommt gar nicht dazu, seine geile Musik mal hochkommen zu lassen, weil die fängt immer an so, wie so ein Orchester fängt an so an, um Klimax hinzuarbeiten und dann fangen wir wieder an zu labern. Können wir nicht sagen, gerade Tage nimmst du den Stroheim raus
und ungerade Tage nehme ich den Stroheim raus.
Weil ich glaube, es würde uns helfen, wenn immer nur
einer von uns den Stroheim im Mund hat.
Man kann auch gut reden mit dem Stroheim im Mund.
Naja, aber ich glaube, wir müssen
ich glaube, wir müssen uns
überlegen, wie wir das machen.
Wir müssen ja auch unterscheidbar sein.
Jedes coole Cowboy-Duo ist
irgendwie Bill und Bob oder irgendwie sowas. Wir heißen beide Paule, was schon mal ein Problem ist. Und wir haben beide als Alleinstellungsmerkmal den Strohhalm. Und jetzt sitzen wir auch noch anders auf dem Pferd, als wir losgeritten sind. Die Leute haben keine Ahnung, wer wir sind. Du wolltest erst meinen Namen haben, dann wollte ich deine Lederjacke auch haben, hab ich auch nachgekauft, wir mussten immer alles nachgekaufen. Ich hab mir Schlangenlederschuhe gekauft, du hast ja auch Schlangenlederschuhe gekauft, am Tag danach und hast gesagt, es war Zufall. Ja, es gibt auch nicht so viele andere coole Lederschuhe. Krokodile gab es auch noch, aber fand ich ein bisschen zu gemein. Ja, ist gemein. Man erlöst sie. Schau dir die Depp mal an. Man erlöst sie. Die darf den Boden rumkriegen. Ja, das ist für mich, erlöst sie eh, weil die sind ja bestraft, auf dem Boden rumkriechen zu müssen. Ja. Und so ein Krokodil kann ich immer noch. So dumm, so dumm. Also habe ich mir Schlangenlederschuhe gekauft. Ja, die sehen schon gut aus. Das sind gute Schuhe. Ich kann ja schon nichts sagen. Von Vance. Wie weit ist es noch bis Little Rock? Leider noch vier Wochen ritt. Noch vier Wochen ritt. Wir kommen leider kaum voran, weil wir leider auch unsere Navigation ein bisschen haben schleifen lassen. Und wir jetzt schon wieder an diesem Geiergerippel hier vorbeikommen. Und ich glaube, da waren wir schon ein paar Mal. Es gibt ja auch viele Geiergerippel. Ja, es gibt sehr viele Geiergerippel und Geier auch. Meinst du, Kautabak wäre was für mich? Weiß nicht, man wird entweder noch nervöser und schnattert es noch mehr rum. Wie viel Kautabak konsumiert man denn pro Tag? Also ist das wirklich... Das wird mir auch gefragt, auch so Pfeifen und so. Was ist denn da so die... Was ist bei Zigaretten, weiß ich auch nicht, was da so eine Tagesdose ist von einem normalen Durchschnittsraucher. Keine Ahnung. Und Tabak, da hat man die ganze Zeit so ein Stückchen im Mund. Und woher weiss man, das habe ich mich auch gefragt die ganze Zeit, weil das war ein sehr regelmäßiges Unterbrechen seiner Speech und dann in diesen Kling Metallschüsselding zu spucken. Kann man nicht einfach Kaugummis kauen und die dann ausspucken? Ich glaube, wieder richtig uncool. Bei Kaugummis weißt du ja, wann du fertig bist, wann der Geschmack weg ist, wenn Huba-Buba nicht mehr nach Huba-Buba schmeckt. Ich glaube, jeder Mensch hat eine Intuition, ab wann es reicht mit dem Kaugummi. Es ist auch ein Moment. Es ist wirklich so, ab einem Moment ist der Zauber vorbei. Oh, glaubst du, man würde Menschen, die sich nicht sehen, gleichzeitig Hüppabuba geben, dass sie gleichzeitig das sagen, Arm hochnehmen, wenn du das Gefühl hast, jetzt ist es vorbei. Jetzt würde ich es normalerweise ausspucken. Aber wirklich, wir sehen die, das ist eine Show, von die du kannst moderiert. Und da ist so eine Trennwand zwischen den, Publikum muss absolut ruhig sein. Publikum ist Motten.
Entweder das oder jeder im Publikum hat auch einen Kaugum bekommen. Ja, sorry.
Ja, wäre es vielleicht einfacher.
Ja, sorry, ich weiß nicht, was das war.
Weil ich glaube, um so ein ganzes Publikum zu füllen, bräuchte man wahnsinnig viele Motten.
Aber leicht zu finden, wir brauchen nur eine Lampe aufhängen.
Mit der Studie liegt dann vielleicht verwirrend.
Das heißt, die kauen, das ganze Publikum kaut.
Wir haben ohnehin schon so ein Grundgeräusch
Das gefällt mir aber auch, so ein Grundkauen.
Aber die hängen nach unten und dann hast du halt irgendwie
Ralf Schmitz gegen
Karolin Kebekus.
Nee, nicht gegen.
Es geht nicht darum, wer zuerst fertig ist mit Kauen.
Es geht darum, dass wir einfach, es geht einmal um
sozusagen einmal die Frage zu beantworten.
Merken alle Menschen zur gleichen Zeit, schmecken alle
Menschen gleich gut. Wie groß ist die Differenz, ja.
Und ich finde eher, es ist Hubba Bubba,
da hat man da so ein Team aus Anwälten und
Marketing-Dools und Head-Offs von
Hubba Bubba, von Juicy Fruit,
von Airways,
Airways Always,
dann von Five Gum und sozusagen
stellt man die gegeneinander auf. Und dann guckt man, wann Karolin Kebekus fertig ist mit Huber-Bubber, dann kommt erst eine 30-minütige Werbeunterbrechung. Sorry, sorry, nochmal ganz kurz, damit ich das verstehe, Herr Tiesel. Es ist keine Gameshow, sondern es ist eine Art Live-Experiment. Ja, es ist auch ein bisschen eine Gameshow mit so einem kompetentiven Charakter, weil natürlich die Marken gegeneinander, die wollen natürlich, dass man das langanhaltendste Kaugummi ist. Also Karolin Kebekus und Ralf Schmitz tun gleichzeitig den Kaugummi in den Mund. Genau, wir können auch sagen, wir machen das Ensemble größer. Ralf Schmitz, Cordula Stratmann, Annette Frier und Martin Schneider. Den kriegt man allen ein Kaugummi. Der Marke Nummer eins, Nummer uno. Brand eins, Juicy Club. Wissen die Kandidaten, welcher es ist? Das wäre mir völlig egal. Alles klar. Dann schreibe ich mir das hier auf. Völlig egal. Völlige Gleichgültigkeit. Völlige Gleichgültigkeit, was diesen Punkt angeht. Da können Sie gerne mitreden. Gut, alles klar. Können Sie einfach entscheiden. Gut. Kann man denen sagen. Okay. Ja. Oder die Raucherarten. Stellt man hin und dann gibt man dem Signal, wann die das Kaugummi nehmen können, dann fangen die an zu kauen. Das Publikum auch zum Teil, alle im Kauen. Auch Moderator, auch nervig, weil er die ganze Zeit auch kaut. Man findet viele Punkte in der Anmoderation und die Regeln der Show nicht verstanden hat. Wegen des Kauen. So, dann gucken alle und dann ist wichtig, gucken alle, das haben sie jetzt so gesagt, also alle gucken minutenlang.
Ja, man könnte ja sagen, Frank Buschmann kann moderieren vielleicht oder so. Alles klar, das schreiben wir auch, ja. Frank Buschmann und Barra Schoenberg. Gleiche Hände nochmal, ja, schreibt dem. Schreibt dem, die können das kommentieren, auch mit Jan Köppen, auch ein lustiges Duo so und gucken dann, wie es läuft. Und dann der Erste, der den Arm hochnimmt, ist wichtig, der hat nicht gewonnen.
Es geht darum, verliert das Kaugummi zeitgleich bei allen den Geschmack. Darum geht die Show. So heißt die Show. Verliert das Kaugummi bei allen zeitgleich den Geschmack. Bei allen Promis zeitgleich. Verliert das Kaugummi bei allen Promis gleichzeitig den Geschmack. Okay. Und wenn ja, warum nicht? Okay. Warum? Ja, ähm, Dankeschön. Das ist mein Pitch. Sie sind leider immer noch der einzige Kreative, der noch Lust hat, für Fernsehen zu pitchen. Das liegt daran, weil ich das Schild vorne, so ein Pitchraum, habe ich nämlich von meinen Wild West-Going gelernt, habe ich einmal umgedreht. Da ist nicht der Pfeil zum Pitchraum, habe ich einfach mal umgedreht um 180 Grad gedreht. Wohingegen bei der Blutspende hunderte kreative Redakteure sitzen da und spenden Blut. Also Win-Win. Ja, ja, sie kommen rein eigentlich, um die Idee zu pitchen, und dann kommen sie raus mit weniger Blumenkörper. Welcher Promi kann am meisten Blut spenden? Ist das eine Show? Nein. Nein? Okay. Hast du meinen Magen gehört? Das war unangenehm jetzt. Hat der Lust auf Blut, dein Magen? Äh, nein. Hast du ein Vampir? Hä? Nein. Moment mal. Was? Tu mal das Mikrofon vor deinem Mund weg. Ich will mal deine Zähne sehen. Nee, was? Warum musst du die jetzt sehen? Hör mal, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Kann es sein, dass du ein Vampir bist? Ach ja. Ich dachte mir bei dieser ganzen Western-Nummer, dass das noch irgendwie ein Crossover ist mit Western und Aliens und jetzt ist es Western und Vampir. Wer denkt sich das denn auch?
Cowboys versus Vampires.
Moment, und die Idee ist, wir reiten ewig lang zusammen und du wartest auf den richtigen Moment, mich zu beißen oder was?
Nee, ja, eigentlich ja, so ist es angefangen. Eigentlich habe ich dich nur ausgeführt quasi, damit ich dich irgendwann in der freien Wildbahn, in der Prärie umbringen kann.
Deswegen auch ein Pferd jetzt, okay, geil. Rückblickend kann man den ganzen Film nochmal angucken.
Ja, bitte, mach das unbedingt auch.
Und sie die kleinen Details.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir uns sowieso gut angefreundet und auch diesen Podcast gestartet vor allen Dingen.
Deswegen möchte ich den nicht mehr umbringen. Jetzt die Frage für Teil zwei, ob du auch, und das können wir erstmal auf und ausdiskutieren im Akt drei jetzt, ob du Bock hast, auch Vampir zu werden oder nicht. Aber ich würde dich jetzt... Dazu müsstest du mich beißen. Genau, dazu würde ich dich beißen, das ist das Regelwerk. Unangenehm, super unangenehm, du stirbst dann. Aber macht dich das satt dann auch? Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist für mich auch, das ist loose, loose. Loose, loose? Ja, aber du lebst halt ewig. Das ist ja die Idee. Aber du weisst auch, warum wir, jetzt macht alles noch mehr Sinn, warum wir immer nachts geritten sind. Oh ja! Genial! Das ist ja perfekt. Weitere Vampire. Jetzt verstehe ich es, ja. Kurz bevor ich sterbe, habe ich dann noch nochmal alles verstanden. Das ist echt nett. Das war, ja. Ich glaube, würde ich jemals ein Blues-Album aufnennen, ich würde es Blues-Blues nennen. Blues-Blues. Blues-Blues-Situation, glaube ich. So würde mein Blues-Album heißen. Hast du jemals ein Blues-Clues gelöst? Nee, es gibt immer diesen Awkward-Moment, wo er dann fragt, und, wie viel habt ihr gefunden? Und ich immer, ja, gar nichts. Ich hätte immer wieder nichts. Sonntag für die Tonne. Ich hatte einmal wieder nur einen, einer aus fünf. Der komplette Sonntag ist ruiniert, wenn man Blues-Clues nicht richtig hinkriegt. Ich habe mich richtig angestrengt, ich bin wirklich mit Augäpfeln an die Flimmerscheibe ran. Ich wollte jeden Hinweis finden, aber habe ihn leider nicht gefunden. Auch immer diese Situation, wenn dieser dumme Kinderchor ruft. Da war ja immer, oh, das ist heiß, und der Kinderchor ruft, was, das ist Eis? Nein, das ist Reis, war das nicht immer so, dass der Kinderchor es immer nichtstanden hat? Oh nee, der Kinderkorps hat immer das Richtige gerufen und er hat immer das Falsche verstanden. Der Kinderkorps hat immer gerufen, du musst zu den Erdbeeren. Was, da gibt es Blaubeeren? Nein, Erdbeeren. Aber wenn du selber dumm bist wie ich und hast auch das Falsche gerufen und der Kinderkoror ruft das Richtige und man denkt so, fuck. Du rufst Blaubeeren! Und der ganze Kindergeruch rufst, was Blaubeeren und du, was? Ja, dachte ich jetzt. Sorry, sorry. Hört der mich? Und man dreht sich so im Kinderchor sitzend um und denkt so, nee, was? Hä? Man hofft, dass sie es nicht gehört haben, aber alle drehen sich zu dir um und man denkt, fuck. Wenn man auch gelernt hat, dass Erwachsene einfach richtig dumm sind, oder? Ist die Botschaft von Blues Clues? Ich glaube, man sollte Kindern von Anfang an eher mitteilen, dass Erwachsene richtig dumm sind. Also so richtig dumm. Man sollte denen sagen, ihr seid viel schlauer. Unterrichtet ihr euch gegenseitig lieber. Kinder sind so... Erwachsenen können nix. Kinder sind cool. Habe ich das erzählt, letzte letzte Woche wo ein Kind stand wie habe ich das erzählt, habe ich das im Podcast erzählt wo ein Kind gefragt hat wo ein Kind am am Brüsseler Platz ja genau, wo ich dachte, ja, das ist das gleiche Ding, Kinder sind cleverer, Kinder sind auch aufrichtiger, Kinder wollen wissen, was los ist und seitdem gehst du du jeden Tag an den Brüsseler Platz, um dieses Kind zu treffen, diese reine Seele. Übrigens, viele Hörer auch, viele Hörer haben uns gesagt, ich gehe zum Brüsseler Platz und will dieses Kind finden. Da noch mal ganz kurz, werft noch mal einen kurzen Blick ins Gesetzbuch, gegen wie viele Gesetze könnt ihr an dem Abend gleichzeitig verstoßen. Las das vielleicht, lass dieses Kind in Ruhe.
Such nicht das Kind.
War das ein bisschen doof von mir, ein bisschen auch indiskret,
auch genau den Ort zu benutzen, wo das Kind ab und so ist. Aber es ist ja ein grosser Platz.
Aber es ist auch nicht alleine da. Es ist nicht, weil das Kind
abends aufbricht und zu diesem Platz geht.
Es ist ja mit ihrer Mutter da wahrscheinlich.
Und die Mutter muss dann gegen Podcast-Ufo-Fans verteidigen,
die da alle ankommen mit ihren hässlichen T-Shirts.
Und dann ankommen und die Mutter muss mit so einem Regenschirm, mit so einem Gässl, das ist der Geister war ein Regenschirm, die alle weghauen dann die ganze Zeit. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Das ist ein gutes Videospiel, also können wir auch nebenbei ein gutes Videospiel machen. Ein Kampf um den Buslerplatz. Ein größer Platz, du musst so ein kleines Kind verteidigen gegen Podcast-Ufo-Fans, die sowieso Zombies aus allen Richtungen angerannt kommen. Was passiert, wenn man die Mutter spielt, aber es nicht schafft? Was machen die Podcast-Ufo-Kinder mit dem Kind? Das musste das Spiel erwerben für 59,99 Euro, um das rauszufinden. Bitte, bitte nicht. Sie wollten Sprachnachricht aufgenommen haben. Bitte einfach Sprachnachricht aufgenommen. Oder Sie wollten die Frage beantworten. Ja, ich komme auch oft zum Brüsseler Platz. Das finde ich gut. Wie gefallen dir Piazzas? Piazzen in Italien? Ist das für dich ein Thema? Ich war jetzt sehr lange nicht mehr auf einer Piazza, aber ich finde es toll. Also Piazzas finde ich super. Warum gibt es in Italien diese Piazze? Die Idee ist, glaube ich, so kleine Get-Together-Places zu machen, ohne jetzt, und das ist in Deutschland total scheiße, weil es ist alles volle Autos. Fahrräder müssen weg, es war auch lustig in der Schweiz, da waren überall immer so Volksabstimmungen. Das ist eine Direktdemokratie, also die wählen ja quasi jeden Sonntag, stimmen die für irgendwas ab. Und dann hängen immer an den Häusern hängen dann immer Ehe für alle, ja, hängen dann immer quasi Fahnen oder Plakate davon, wie man abstimmt in dem Haushalt gerade, also so Werbeplakate. Die können Privatpersonen einfach aufhängen und die beziehen dann Stellung. Und ein direkt, ich habe da gewohnt bei einem Kumpel und direkt gegenüber hing ein großes Plakat, wo draufstehen, endlich sichere Radwege, ja. Und ich dachte, das ist eure Abstimmung, weil so Ehe für alle so, man kennt Leute, die dagegen sind, furchtbar, aber okay. Ja, es ist denkbar zumindest, ja. Es ist auf eine furchtbare Art denkbar, dagegen zu sein.
Dann zum Beispiel, also es ist Realität. Und dann gibt es auch so was, keine Ahnung, Besteuerung, 99%-Regel, irgendwie superkrasse Besteuerung der Superreichen und so. Auch da versteht man, dass Superreichen zum Beispiel dagegen sein könnten, dass ihre ganze Rechnung besteuert wird. Wobei, bei bessere Radwege, nein. Nee, auch der Frage, endlich sichere Radwege, Fragezeichen, frage ich mich, welche Personifizierung des Bösen macht da nein? Also das ist ja auch Satan vielleicht. Ja, vielleicht. Aber ich verstehe es nicht, weil ich finde, das ist so eine lustige Frage. Autofahrer, aber es gibt ja, ich dachte immer, es gibt nicht Gut und Böse in der Welt, das ist alles ein bisschen vielschichtiger, aber bei so einer Frage. Ich glaube, die Schweiz hat gerade bei Verkehr eine grosse Vertrauensschwierigkeit nach dieser Huhn-Nummer und dem Teufel, der einfach bei endlich sicheren Brücken, endlich teufelsfreien Brücken da den Stein auf das Dorf geworfen hat. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es tief sitzt in der Schweiz, dass die auch bei Radwegen einfach Schwierigkeiten haben. Das finde ich so lustig. Was für personifizierte böse Menschen. Ich würde gerne vor so einem Wahllokal stehen und gucken, ob da einfach so ein Comic-Buch-Bösewicht rausgeht oder so Darth Vader oder so weiter. Ich kenne das aus Star Wars. Böse und gut. Ein großer schwarzer Helm. Ein schwarzer Ritter. Oder nein, endlich sichere Radwege, nein, nein, lasst sie weiter uns! So ein Town-Villain einfach, der Zürcher Town-Villain. Aber auch so verschiedenste Bösewichte irgendwie, so der dunkle, der schwarze Ritter, Darth Vader, irgendwie so ein Voldemort kommt dann vorbei, irgendwie alle Stimmen. Der von Crazy Town, mit dieser ... Oh ja, genau, der Sporttyp, Dr. Sport, mit diesen Dagen-Augenbra. Gagameels am fucking Start. Und halt die Daltons, die vier Stimmen haben. Und halt die vier fucking Daltons. Ja, das stimmt. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, dann waren auch diese Plakate von Ehe für alle und so, und dann haben dann die progressiven Jungen dafür abgestimmt, haben auch sehr viel dafür abgestimmt, also war super. Aber ich dachte mir auch dafür, das ist ja auch quasi super böse, dagegen zu sein, gegen die Liebe zu stimmen. Das sind so ein paar Abstimmungen, die es einfach gibt. Du brauchst Bösewichte, du brauchst Bösewichte in der Geschichte, du brauchst einfach die Leute. Ist ja auch nicht leicht, der Bösewicht zu sein, glaube ich. Wenn du mal wirklich glaubst, da gibt es eh Selbsthilfegruppen für die, die sagen, eigentlich habe ich nichts gegen Luke Skywalker. Ich meine, soll der noch machen, was er will? Das ist schon irre, weil man denkt das ja im echten Leben nicht. Da war mal so ein Fernsehbeitrag über die Leute, die dann gegen die Ehe für alle gestimmt haben. Und es war einfach so ein Haufen Bösewichte. Nichts an denen ist ja ehrenhaft oder sinnvoll oder nachvollziehbar. Es ist einfach eine merkwürdige Ansammlung von Menschen, die so... Und dann fragt man sich ja, warum die Stormtrooper fein damit waren, auf dem Todesstern zu sein und fürs Gute zu kämpfen, die wussten doch, dass sie fürs Böse kämpfen. Und dann dachte man, das macht keinen Sinn. Aber die Menschen sind gegen die Ehe für alle. Was ist deren Moralkodex? Es sind einfach böse Menschen. Wenn du so eine coole Maske hast irgendwie und dann hast du so Farbe im Gesicht und dann rote Lichtwert. So und dann denkst du, ja das ist schon cool.
Dann musst du das halt auch machen. Du kannst ja nicht
dann gesehen werden, wie du dann
als Doctor Evil, als der Manta rochen,
dann da irgendwie in der Schlange stehst
für ja. Das funktioniert nicht. Es wäre jetzt merkwürdig, wenn
aussieht wie Darth Maul
mit Hörnern und rotem,
seine Hautfarbe ist rot-schwarz
und er hat Hörner. Und du hast Hörner und du hast
gelbe Augen. Star Wars war nie sehr subtil, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Und du hast gelbe, dämonische Augen. Es würde dich wundern, wenn du bei Ehe für alle für Jagd bist. Ja, du musst es dann auch durchziehen. Ja. Du musst es durchziehen. Der gefallene Engel, der gefallene Icarus ist ja auch ein klassischer Bösewicht geworden, glaube ich. Wissen wir nicht. Das funktioniert. Wissen wir nicht. Wurde abgeschafft, die Bank. Aber falls ihr es wisst, schreibt es uns. Und ansonsten freuen wir uns auf viele tolle TV-Shows. Ich möchte mich noch mal ganz explizit bedanken bei dem Einsender von unserem Intro heute, der uns auf das Western-Thema gebracht hat, Marius. Vielen Dank. Marius, thank you very much. Dead or Alive, vielen Dank für dieses Intro. Wir reiten hier schön weiter nach Little Rock und lassen euch in den nächsten zehn Folgen wieder teilhaben, wie wir da langsam abkommen.
Wir sind noch eine Weile unterwegs, wir reiten in den Horizont, ich würde sagen, wir reiten ab.